last Friday the NFL admitted that the  number of players diagnosed with  concussions continues to rise it  continues to go up so the NFL is wants  to do something about this okay  they are now taking a much tougher  stance and they say that they're  introducing a very thorough protocol to  make sure that players are really okay  before they let them play again now I'm  all in favor of that  I just think they've gone a little too  far take a look what day is it  who's the president drunk who's the vice  president it's named Kim Kardashian's  kids North st. and Chicago bronze is  made of copper and tin brass is made of  copper and nickel how many companies  make up the Nasdaq 3300 Billy Callen  said he was the second unit director on  the movie speed 3.14159265 3.14159265  three greater doesn't  [Applause]  you